the Joe Rogan experience there's you
know studies show to that I guess one of
that biggest opinion formers still that
people kind of write off because it's
not as sexy and big is local news you
know local news is huge at forming
opinions but I believe it yeah I believe
it it's it's so fascinating to me and
then this Facebook thing is fascinating
to me too because they were you know we
were talking about Facebook yesterday
that what we were watching this you know
when he was being grilled
yeah Zuckerberg yeah one of the things
they were talking about upcoming
elections international he's talking
about how Facebook is really you know we
have to concentrate on all these
upcoming elections and make sure there's
no bad actors that are yeah like what
like Facebook is involved in shaping the
world it's incredible yeah I you see I
saw an article about how they said that
the senators that grilled him missed so
many things basically because they're
old they're just like they didn't ask so
many questions because they don't
understand how even Facebook works yeah
there's a funny video that I put up
Jamie see if you find it oh it's on
Twitter of some of the more hilarious
things that came out of that interaction
mmm-hmm and one of them was the guy asks
Zuckerberg would you tell us the hotel
you're staying at he's like no like
would you be willing to tell us and show
us all the messages all the messages
that you've sent he's like no like this
back up back it up last night vert Iser
or campaign who who asked for it mr.
Zuckerberg would you be comfortable
sharing with us the name of the hotel
you stayed in last night no
if you messaged anybody this week would
you share with us the names of the
people you've messaged a senator no I
would probably not choose to do that
publicly here I think that maybe what
this is all about here's what
everybody's been trying to tell you they
you know I say this gently your User
Agreement sucks I'm gonna suggest to you
that you go back home and rewrite it and
tell your $1200 an hour log there's no
disrespect
they're good but but tell them you want
it written in English and non Swahili so
the average American can understand that
would be a start quite a story there's
no competition that's what's really
weird yeah like as far as like there's
Twitter yeah that is just it's it's cool
that we have these three different ones
too which is really fascinating
you got Twitter which is just some text
like I saw this article check it out and
then people retweet it I like that
aspect yeah and then you know you could
state your opinion on things you'd
clarify things but then there's
instagrams just photos hey this is my
time in Peru look at the beautiful
buildings they own that one that's not a
competitor right yeah but I mean the
three different zones and then there's
Facebook which is like a lot of
arguments in discussion deep discussion
politics that's like the big one when it
comes to like deep political discussions
it's I wonder what it's coming next
because these we typically people
transmission cycles you know I know
you're right but I feel like I don't
know they have it they have a pretty
strong grip I mean you know snapchat is
is really popular but as soon as
snapchat looked like it was about to
just really explode and meaning that it
would be the kind of premiere you know a
visual one Instagram was like we're
gonna add that that same aspect to yeah
Instagram stories just squash that
yeah it's just Instagram it's a better
platform but it's it's just really
interesting to see like what we choose
to put our time in our energy in and
where it's going and when is the first
virtual reality or augmented reality
social network going to it's gotta be
around the learner yeah they must be
like scrambling to be the first to come
up with it because if you can like if
you tried there was a thing called views
there still is a thing called views I
got on it I told the watch people to get
on it I haven't even opened it in
[ __ ] month people put a cup v you se
I put a couple pictures up and then I
was like I gave up I'm gonna signed up
for it but yeah I can't do another one
right now yeah I'm here o ver oh well
see let me know what's causing yeah I
forgot his [ __ ] name
[Applause]